The final trailer for the upcoming third season
of Stranger Things drops plenty of hints about
the characters' journeys.
We also get some big clues about the villains
of the season, as well as a few obligatory
'80s Easter eggs.
Let's take a look at the small details you
may have missed.
The third season of Stranger Things will be
the first that doesn't take place during Halloween.
Netflix revealed that season 3 would be dropping
on Independence Day 2019 with a special date
announcement, and the 4th of July holiday
will also be the setting of the show this
year.
The final season 3 trailer opens with a wide
shot of a 4th of July fun fair sponsored by
Mayor Kline.
A new character for season 3, Larry Kline
is portrayed by Cary Elwes, star of '80s classic
The Princess Bride.
"But in the meantime, rest well and dream
of large women."
Promotional materials for the show describe
Kline as "handsome, slick and sleazy… your
classic '80s politician."
It looks like the mayor will be a secondary
villain of sorts, but could his arc tie in
to a previously unexplored plot?
We're going back to Hawkins in the summer
of 1985, at the height of the Cold War.
Theory crafters are predicting that the Duffers
will return to the Russian spy subplot planted
by journalist-turned-private investigator
Murray Bauman in season 2.
"Russian spies!
Are the Russian spies in cahoots with the
aliens?
Or how do they fit in here?"
"It doesn't make sense.
I closed the gate."
With that line, Eleven is obviously referring
to the moment she used her psychokinetic powers
to seal the portal to the Upside Down at the
end of season 2, seemingly saving Hawkins
from the monstrous creatures that dwell on
the other side.
It didn't take a genius to figure out that
the Upside Down would feature in the coming
third season, however, and the final trailer
confirms that this will indeed be the case.
We see Eleven in her sense-depriving blindfold
early on in the trailer, surrounded by her
concerned friends.
Her trademark nosebleed tells us that she's
using her special abilities, and the following
shot shows that she's in the hellscape that
is the Upside Down, standing in front of a
large steelworks warehouse.
This warehouse appears to be the hideout of
the evil that will be unleashed this coming
season.
We see a swarm of rats converging on the place,
and a dark smoke-like entity whirling its
way through the empty corridors.
But is this entity a new foe, or one the gang
has faced before?
Inside the Brimborn warehouse there's a brief
but unmistakable shot of the Mind Flayer,
the creature that took control of Will Byers
in season 2.
The young heroes of Hawkins thought they'd
locked the Mind Flayer in the Upside Down,
but as Byers points out, they don't know that
for sure.
"What if we locked him out here with us?"
Byers is clearly still connected to the Mind
Flayer in some way, and he drops a huge clue
about the malevolent entity's intentions for
season 3 in the last trailer, saying that
it'll be looking for a new host.
The face of Billy Hargrove appears onscreen
as Byers utters the words, heavily implying
that the season 2 bully will become an even
bigger threat to the kids this time out.
There's an ominous voiceover in the trailer
that has everybody scratching their heads.
It begins right at the start of the trailer,
playing over some lingering shots of our tween
heroes.
"You let us in."
The same voice can be heard later in the trailer:
"We are going to end you, we are going to
end your friends."
The owner of the voice is never identified,
and there are a lot of theories, but listen
closely, and voice sounds an awful lot like
Jake Busey, a new addition to the Stranger
Things cast.
He's playing a character called Bruce, a reporter
from The Hawkins Post who has, quote, "questionable
morals and a sick sense of humor."
Is he going to be an important villain?
Well put it this way: it's probably no coincidence
that Busey's character shares a name with
the shark from Steven Spielberg's Jaws.
"Bruce got his name because my lawyer's name,
I named the shark after my lawyer.
He's still my lawyer by the way."
We got our first good look at season 3 newbie
Maya Hawke in the Starcourt mall teaser that
Netflix dropped in July 2018.
Hawke plays a character named Robin, a co-worker
of Steve Harrington at the sparkly new mall's
Scoops Ahoy ice cream parlor.
The first season 3 trailer showcased Robin
in this capacity, but now we know for sure
that she's going to be doing way more than
just scooping ice cream − there's a shot
of her peering through a glass door at something
that's probably not from this dimension.
Another bewildering moment in the trailer
is when Steve and Dustin unearth a canister
filled with something peculiar, and judging
by what Harrington is wearing at the time,
he's in the middle of a shift at Scoops Ahoy.
It's one of the standout shots from the final
trailer, and it seems to indicate that something
is going on in the bowels of the Starcourt
mall.
The next two shots feature people in hazmat
suits gathered around what appears to be some
kind of particle collider.
The machine fires up and shoots a white beam
of energy, which could well be the cause of
the blackout at the end of the trailer.
But who is experimenting under the mall?
"It's alive"
The Hawkins National Laboratory was shut down
after it was linked to the death of season
1 fan favorite Barbara Holland, though there
are bound to be plenty of other interested
parties when it comes to unlocking the secrets
of the Upside Down.
There's lots of quick editing in the final
season 3 trailer, but if you watch it back
a couple of times you'll notice that a few
different teams seem to have formed by the
end.
Eleven, Mike, and Max cower together behind
a counter, while Will, Jonathan, Nancy, and
Lucas take cover behind a battered car.
Steve, Dustin, Robin, and Erica appear to
escape the mall.
Lastly, there are the adults: Hopper, Joyce
and Murray.
Joyce Byers had a thing with Sean Astin's
Bob Newby in season 2, but the Radio Shack
manager was killed helping the gang escape.
Bob wasn't unpopular, but most Stranger Things
fans have been shipping a Joyce-Hopper relationship
since the early days of the show.
A blink-and-you'll-miss-it moment in the final
trailer all but confirms that they'll make
the leap in season 3.
The shot is a close-up of two unidentified
people holding hands.
Pause it, and you'll notice that the shirts
they're wearing match the ones worn by Joyce
and Hopper earlier in the trailer.
David Harbour is aware of how much people
want this, and he gets it.
"The fans, they call it like 'Jopper,' or
something.
They all ship this relationship with Hopper
and Joyce and I do too, because I feel like
they're two really lonely, lost people."
Stranger Things just wouldn't be Stranger
Things without all the '80s Easter eggs, and
there are going to be plenty of those in the
upcoming third season.
Ross Duffer kept his cards close when IndieWire
asked him which films he and his brother would
be referencing this time out, but the final
season 3 trailer contains a few subtle clues.
Lucas, for example, wears an outfit reminiscent
of The Karate Kid.
One of the most blatant nods to an iconic
movie comes when Max, Eleven and Mike take
cover behind a counter in the mall.
The shot is super similar to the kitchen scene
from Jurassic Park, which is of course an
early '90s movie, but seeing as it's directed
by Steven Spielberg, it's fair game.
The Duffer brothers have made no secret of
the fact that they're heavily into Spielberg,
naming E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial, Close Encounters
of the Third Kind, and Jaws as big influences.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.